welcome back everyone many women put off
getting their annual health exams in
2020 but now that we're climbing out of
the pandemic finally
it is time to put your health care at
the top of the to-do list denise valdez
has today's buddy check-in report
[Music]
if you've been doing your monthly
self-breast exams good for you
but the gold standard is still a
mammogram a long-time nevadan and
familiar face
shelly berkeley postponed her exam
during the pandemic
but explains why now she's eager to get
it done
and you've had a mammogram with us
before many times
educator and former politician shelly
berkley has been getting
annual mammograms for more than 25 years
her life depends on it i get a mammogram
every year because every woman in my
family
from my great-grandmother's on have died
of breast cancer
so it's obviously a disease that's
prevalent in my family
and i'm going to be the first woman in
my family not to die from breast cancer
are you all ready yes i am come on
around she's returning to steinberg
diagnostic
a facility that monitors her medical
history
dr anshu shah is director of women's
imaging
most importantly we look for changes in
the mammogram and that's why
radiologists are always emphasizing that
we bring in prior films because subtle
changes in your mammogram from year to
year
can be made sometimes the only clue that
we have that there may be something
going on
it's recommended women start getting the
procedure at 40
unless like berkeley you have a history
of breast cancer in your family
but first-timers might still be
apprehensive it's our job to
relax them a little bit explain to them
that it's really not as painful
as some of the stories out there this
veteran
urges women to not be afraid and book
that appointment
it's not the most comfortable thing in
the world
but it certainly is not painful it
you get it done and you know what you
live to talk about it the following year
most mammograms take about 15 minutes
now 3d imaging has drastically improved
the resolution
creating more detailed pictures so there
are now fewer call backs and much more
confidence for both the radiologists
and their patients for buddy check
denise valdez 8 news now